Before dawn this morning, on Iguni Street,
a group of carnivores attacked
a 22-year-old Thomson's gazelle, Linda,
and killed her by biting her neck.
Well, there are lots of horrifying crimes
going on out there.
...suspects are still on the run.
According to the witness...
-This is not good.
-...a gray wolf...
-I'll go back to the dorm.
-...a coyote and Canidae...
You guys won the game.
But you were winning...
As the Canidae is sociable
and highly bonded...
Don't worry. It's nothing unusual.
DEVOURING CASE
SUSPECTS ON THE RUN
To be honest, we carnivores are used to
this kind of uncomfortable situation.
No! Let go of me!
Look at the news!
They say that the leader of the suspects
is a gray wolf.
I'm not like them!
-That's how everybody sees you!
-They're not just teasing her.
How would I help her?
Hey, you!
Well, this is complicated.
Maybe I shouldn't put my nose
into other people's business.
Are you listening to me?
If you are one of them,
show me what you've got.
Excuse me?
I'm her brother.
What is going on?
Her... brother?
Yes.
Shoot! She doesn't look like me at all.
-Liar! She doesn't look like you at all.
-That's right!
I look like our father
and she looks like our mother.
Are you all right?
Thanks, bro...
Let's go.